eco-friendly ones that kept track of
things smart water bottles i've just
never done it yeah dude i'm fine they
called me hose water was my middle name
in high school i'm
like
i
[Music]
all right do you want to do a recap on
rob dierdick because i've been getting
blown up about
about that blown up
yeah this is i would say definitely the
mo the biggest reaction we've had to an
episode in a long time maybe ever ever
as i'd probably say ever the the the one
thing that i got was basically people
said
this is not just
the best podcast you guys have done but
this is maybe the best episode i've ever
listened to of any podcast and i don't
it definitely wasn't us that made it
great but he was pretty amazing right
he was and i didn't know how it would
turn out i remember literally being
amazed in the moment like the things he
was saying were very surprising to me
and very interesting and i wanted to
know more and he told he was very open
so that was dope as well
but you never know like how the episode
turns out and there's all these
different factors you know from audio
quality to like do people care what this
person has to say are they interested
what we're interested in well people
definitely dug it yeah you're right
people were saying like
my top three podcast episodes this year
was naval on tim ferriss rob on your
guys's pod and then whatever some reply
all podcast that happened so it was like
not just this is y'all's best but this
is one of the best i've heard and there
was people tweeting like all right this
is the fourth person that mentioned this
to me i gotta go listen to this today so
something definitely happened i'm
curious in the numbers what that's gonna
show uh in a couple of years they're
good i've looked at them he okay so rob
dierdick on the podcast mentioned his
schedule
and i was curious about it and so i
actually asked him to email me um what
that looked like and he sent me a
screenshot i sent it to you sean can you
read what it what it's what it is and um
basically like at first glance what does
it look like when you see his schedule
it's a picture of his gmail
or his calendar
so it looks like well there's a few
there's a few views but uh the one i'm
looking at it looks like i would say a
combination between like a p l like uh
you know a business's p l cash flow
statement
and or like you know just like a
research doc put out by uh gartner about
you know the trends of an industry this
doesn't look like one person's
you know weekly schedule
and if you look at the view of his
calendar every single minute of his day
is marked off
every minute
yeah it's blocked off now some of it is
like you know it could be like whatever
free time or something like that like
family and kids right so it's not saying
he's working all the time but every
minute is is accounted for every minute
has a purpose
and uh
it says here i track every hour of every
day throughout the day and tag each
entry i have a script written that pulls
and pulls the time and populates into
these two spreadsheets
one is daily time use and the other is
monthly averages so should we do the
should we look at his monthly average
real quick yeah yeah all right so
monthly average we'll take um
we'll take september okay so september
he's got sleep which was 6.9 hours
uh health 1.2 hours
life which is like kind of like family
and things like that 7.8 hours and then
work
uh 8.1 hours per day and it's pretty
consistent like work never in any month
in the whole year the lowest month was
february 5.8 hours and the highest month
was october 9.3 hours right uh sleep
almost always 6.8 or 6.9 hours per day
so this is a pretty meticulous
um meticulous thing and by the way in
the work category he's got like tv shows
right here's my tv shows here's how many
hours i'm spending on tv shows not
watching tv making tv
yeah
yeah making tv making his tv shows
um and then there's like the dudek
machine which is kind of like his
business that builds businesses and then
there's other which is you know random
meetings and stuff like that um very
cool very cool in health he's got gym
meditation personal care other uh for
life he's got you know him and his wife
kids friends and social and then other
right so this is this is sick do you
think okay so let's let's let's talk
about this just for two seconds do you
think that this does this work for you
because by the way i'm saying this out
loud but i i'm gonna package this if if
he's okay with it i'm gonna package this
and post it somewhere
it's a visual thing so we should
basically like you know on twitter and
newsletter i'll put on my newsletter too
but like we should post this so people
can see it if he's cool with it we'll
ask him yeah and do you think that do
you roll this way because
you and i joke like the best days are
when there's nothing on the calendar and
when people cancel stuff and and that
feels like the best day to me although
sometimes i feel lazy and sometimes i
feel meaningless but do you do you like
to operate this way or do you like to
operate with open calendar or what
so i'll tell you some of my uh i'll tell
you two things i'll tell you about my
calendar philosophy do i want to be
scheduled or unscheduled i want to be
the opposite of this i want to be
completely unscheduled
um and you know i don't know why that is
the case it used to be the opposite so
my calendar used to look a lot like his
i used to block out like
i used to just do it at high level like
work block one
lunch work block two
gym
you know family time
yeah end of night kind of like hobby you
know reading random random [__] or
whatever i used to just kind of like
schedule out my day like that and try to
keep it um and then i would have like in
in a week i would have one day like i
still have this i have one day where i
do 90 minutes of random meetings meaning
people that are just find interesting i
just want to meet with no agenda and
just kind of like cool people meeting
cool people and so i do schedule time
for randomness
but for the most part
i've gone away from having a highly
scheduled day to having an unscheduled
day meaning i don't schedule it in
advance on the day of
i decide what i'm gonna do and i decide
how i'm gonna spend today but i don't
decide that like two weeks in advance
and so when somebody says can we meet i
have a simple rule it's like do i want
to meet you if you want to do a call you
want to meet me do i want to meet you
right now if so i'm going to say would
you like to do it right now
if not i'll say i can't do right now but
i'll give you a call in an hour or two
hours from now and if i don't want to do
it right now i say sorry i don't want to
meet and i don't schedule it for like
three weeks from now which is what i
used to do i used to say i don't wanna
do this okay yeah i'm free two weeks but
then guess what two weeks shows up and
then i'm like [__] i gotta do this call
i didn't wanna do then i definitely
don't wanna do it now it's expired yeah
it keeps me up the night before
sometimes
yeah so i'm i'm much more of an
unscheduled person um but the day of i
decide how i'm gonna use today's time
yeah it uh his his calendar was amazing
to me and i think that it's going to be
quite popular when you post that maybe
uh maybe um we'll have to divvy up who
could post what because we could i i
both didn't get the gold yeah um all
right
so let me ask you did you ever do this
time tracking [__] because i also went
through like an aggressive time tracking
phase and i wanted to share one learning
from that um i wouldn't i was never
aggressive about it no i i um i prefer
open time and uh i prefer working from
midnight until like 3 a.m when and
that's when i do a lot of my gold and
stuff so like if i have to copyright
what i if i have to do any type of
copywriting i
will i'll hang out all day and read and
have fun and sarah's like when are you
gonna do work i'm like when you go to
bed and so she'll go to bed and then
from midnight to three sometimes
midnight to four i can get i can do gold
and golden work around that around that
hour i
have a theory about this so fur khan who
was my technical co-founder of my
previous company he's been on the pod he
was the same way he would i would like
he would roll into work at 11 11 30.
he'd start his work day with lunch and
like you would think this is the laziest
guy ever but actually he was he's
massively hard working he was just up
till five in the morning on average yeah
and so you know five in the morning then
he sleeps you know six hours he wakes up
at 11 and he comes into work and um and
even when he was at work like we would
take like an hour we just play video
games we would just like and i was just
like dude like
why do you use your time this way he
goes
he goes i don't know i just oh i just
figured this out for myself early on
which is that like the time i act like
during the day it's just like i'm
basically just trying to exhaust myself
like i want to have conversations i kind
of manage other people i kind of read
[__] i'll talk to people i'll eat lunch
i'll go work out i'll do all the stuff
he's like i'm basically just trying to
get myself really like like i needed my
brain to slow down
and i want to get in this almost like
half sleepy state which is not sleepy
the way most people think about it most
people think sleepy means you can't
function but there is a point where
you're like kind of tired you know you
get kind of loopy yeah yeah and it's
like that's when you could do creative
work for him programming is creative
work so he's like dude from like
midnight to 4am
i write the best code and it's basically
like only my hands are moving i don't
want to get up nobody bothers me nobody
talks to me i don't have to meet anybody
i just and i just go into flow state and
i just work during that time and that's
kind of what you're describing is you're
midnight to 3 a.m i have that same thing
and i've i figured out through furcon
that there's this thing that happens
where if you're trying to do creative
work
you need to be more relaxed and less
kind of like distracted and also like a
little loopy is good because it adds a
little bit of like serendipity into your
brain your brain's willing to play with
different ideas and go in different
directions maybe it's over copywriting
you kind of want something like that
also i believe 23andme has a like a line
item on one of their attributes uh and
it talks about are you a night owl or an
early an early person and i so i think
that a lot of this stuff of when you're
going to get your creative work done i
actually think it's genetic and whatever
it is you should just go all in on it
for example i mean the world's set up
for early risers you know if you if you
get up at 5 a.m and get stuff done like
rob did or like you win you win like
it's the world's setup so you actually
if you're a night person like i am or
you am you kind of got to go against the
grain which sucks but uh here's a good
example the founder of box the ceo of
box what's his name ben levy
aaron sorry that's it ben leaves my guys
aaron levy aaron levy uh close to a
billionaire maybe hundreds of millions a
millionaire uh founder of a
multi-billion dollar company i was
friends with his assistant and she would
tell me that he has no meetings until 11
a.m and that's typically when he starts
at the office because he works until 5am
and by the way bezos is the opposite
bezos is like
i want all my meetings from 8 a.m to
noon all important decisions i need to
make by then because my brain is
functioning the best and then after that
i don't want to have any important
meetings in the day i'll have other
meetings but no just no key decisions no
heavy topics with important like stuff
to digest i want to do other work during
that time and so and like you know rob
dyrdek on his calendar here it's 4 30
a.m wake up wake up call pretty much
every single day one one day he sleeps
until 5 a.m uh you know so he's a little
bit different cat i think it's you know
what works for you and uh and then you
want to play to that like i spent many
years trying to be like uh i want to
wake up at 5 a.m so i can be more
productive and it's just like
waking up three hours earlier was way
harder for me than just staying up three
hours later
and so it's like why am i fighting
what's easy for me what feels like play
to me versus what feels like an absolute
grind to me and it's sort of
unsustainable it's all willpower based
and so you know i made that shift but
i'll give you one thing that's that is
worth doing
so
i tried to like track every hour to see
how i'm using it because i kind of want
you know time is your most precious
asset so i wanted to see how it gets
spent
that was a little bit exhausting
hopefully someday there's going to be
tools that just make this easy so it's
like it just happens passively
but one thing that is amazing is a
calendar audit i don't know if you've
ever done one of these it's a calendar
audit or some people call it an energy
audit it basically means you take for
one week you sort of keep track of like
roughly how you used each hour
and um and then what you do is the next
week you just go back you just pull up
last week's calendar and you take three
colored markers you take a green marker
a red marker and a yellow marker
and you go back through your week how
you spent your time and you say what
which block which thing i did gave me
energy i marked those green
which felt like it sucked all the energy
out of me i was drained afterwards and i
felt like my soul had been sucked out of
me let me mark those red and then the
neutral things let me mark yellow and
you look at the painting you know you
look at your color and you're like wow
that's a lot of red or hey that's
actually pretty good that's a lot of
green and then you just audit and so
you're all you're doing is just trimming
the fat and you just say all right cool
this week i'm going to do less of the
red stuff i'm going to do less by just
literally avoiding it by automating it
or delegating it and you just make a
decision you just improve it by one week
and you just do that every so often and
if you do that it's an amazing way to
manage not your calendar as in like
maximizing efficiency but maximizing
your energy so that you feel good and
you are um when you feel your best
you're going to you know perform your
best at work i think sometimes i think
babe's version of you bezos said the
stuff that you should eliminate is you
you you can answer that by uh asking
will this uh work just fine if i don't
make this decision or if i don't if i
don't attend this or do this will life
be okay if yes then
eliminate it
right um do you want to talk about some
ideas
yeah let's do some other stuff
which uh where do you want to go well
i've got a lot a lot
yeah we both got a lot so we haven't we
have a couple episodes worth of stuff
here give me one off yours that you're
really into okay um have you heard of
brewmate
no and i'm not a coffee drinker is it a
coffee drinking thing it doesn't have to
be so okay so brewmate it's spelled bru
m-a-t-e their first thing was like a
koozie basically their first product was
it was a koozie something that
interested me about this and now they
make tumblers so basically what's a
tumbler like just a coffee drink thermos
like a thermos thing they make a koozie
they make a water bottle they just make
cups for cold stuff and hot stuff and
uh the reason why this interested me is
trends my company trends trends.co we
did a story on broommate and they
interviewed the founder and they did a
good job and i think julia wrote it and
they got a picture of the revenue so
check this out
jacob who's the founder jacob grew
broommate to 20 million in revenue
without a single
employee and so this company launched in
2016. their revenue was basically uh
uh 2016 nothing 2017 it looks uh single
digit hundreds of thousands maybe close
to a million 2018 uh getting close to 20
million in revenue 2019 over 25 million
in revenue 2020 100 million in revenue
and he did most everything with agencies
and contractors and not a single
full-time employee until after 20
million in revenue and it got me
thinking one that's amazing that's like
the greatest thing ever if you ask me i
think that's like the the ideal business
and number two these water bottle and
cup businesses this is something that
like if you told me you're gonna start
that and be like dude that's the
stupidest thing i've ever heard of what
are you doing i there are so many
example examples of some of these things
that are huge for example there's a
business called swell you know swell
water bottles
no i by the way i'm
since college i've been the type of
person that just never uses water
bottles me neither i'm like but i buy
that child i go to water fountains and i
just like put my mouth on the [__]
thing and i drink from a water fountain
that's what i do and everybody else had
these like amazing elaborate
water bottles always eco-friendly ones
that kept track of things smart water
bottles i've just never done it yeah
dude i'm fine they called me hose water
was my middle name in high school i'm
like
i don't know
i wish i had made that up as a dig on
you calling your host water but that's
so perfect
i thought i was going low bar like my
low class thing was a water fountain
and you like showed me
yeah like if there was like a new coke
product that was hose-watered flavor
like from missouri i'd be drinking that
[__] because that's what i grew up on so
i'm not like by the way can we share
this we uh
so the interview we did with brian
halligan the ceo of hubspot they're
playing it at inbound which is the huge
marketing conference i think that's the
ad for the podcast or something is
inbound go to inbound great so uh
they're playing the the the recording
there as an interview and so for weeks
uh for weeks our guy has been our you
know producer of the pod
the old producer of the pod was
badgering us like hey guys they need
this intake form and like you know i'm
just like allergic to words like that so
you know what's that jeff bezos thing
can what happens if i don't do this that
was my my take and it was yours too
uh it was like hey guys i need you to
fill this out i need you to sign this
waiver saying you're okay with the
content being on there i'm like dude i'm
okay with it like obviously it's a
public free podcast you can just use it
wherever you want um and they're like no
no you gotta sign this thing i'm like oh
my god i gotta download a pdf and figure
out how to sign this so weeks go by me
and sam both do nothing at one point
he goes hey sam uh that intake form you
know they're really asking me for it
sam goes oh you could tell
and he's just joking but we we basically
we didn't do it right and so another
week goes by he goes all right guys i
really need this intake form so we we're
like fine all right we signed the thing
and he's like oh i also need a bio for
you um and it's like what's your what's
your job title what's your bios like i
don't know dude i host a podcast and i
like build random businesses that like
it's not i don't have a job title and i
don't have like a bio for you and so i
just wrote future owner of the la lakers
and then uh
future owner of a lake
[Laughter]
it's true man it's true i think that's
the difference between us
i embody the difference between us so
perfectly yeah it was it was amazing all
right back back to the regularly
you can cut you can cut that part out if
you're gonna get fired for that thing no
you can keep that uh keep it we don't
delete it
so this is stupid it's not stupid yeah
and so there's this thing called swell
look up swell look up swell it's a water
bottle i'm not a water bottle guy either
it looks like the dumbest thing ever i
mean it's not dumb it just looks like
the most normal thing ever then there's
corksicle which is basically a cork
water bottle over 80 million in revenue
and then there's one called bkr i
actually don't know how to say that
beaker but
i don't know they didn't they sell a
water bottle for 185 dollars
it's glass and this one's actually cool
because i hate metal water bottles and i
hate plastic it's glass but it has like
plastic or like rubber around it so you
don't shatter it anyway
um
who would have thought
who would have thought yeah crazy uh and
did he say how he scaled because this is
one of the most aggressive scaling
business i've ever heard of so to go
from basically
sub 1 million to 18 million in one year
and then to go from like i don't know
looks like maybe 30 million to 100
million you know these are huge jumps
um
facebook ads and so basically he said
that so he didn't spend a dime so or
sorry he didn't build anything so he
created a landing page and then he drove
facebook ads to it uh and he got a
pre-launch email list of six thousand
people and then he sent those folks an
email to buy it and they bought it and
he used that money to go and build the
product
it's classic
yeah a classic way so kind of
interesting
um and so that's not an idea but i just
wanted to bring that up
no that's cool i like that one um yeah
do we have anything to rip off that or
just like you know props to this guy no
props to that guy but uh that's it
and it looks like he used a bunch of
like um like working capital is always
very hard for e-commerce businesses and
so it looks like you know he couldn't
get a line of credit early so he did
pre-sales and then okay he did pre-sales
then he through the pre-sales now he got
an expensive line of credit so um
you know he got he got an sba loan he
got shopify capital paypal working
capital amazon lending he would use one
to pay the next and that just like let
him roll over one from one line of
credit to the next dude in a way after
doing an audit he got a 2 million line
of credit and now raised 20 million
dollars in a way i think that these
people are so audacious and here's why
if you told me if this guy i don't know
what his name is uh if you told me that
you're going to launch a water bottle
i'll be like jacob you're an idiot this
is the stupidest thing ever and you know
who else i would have said that too
movement watches so this guy also named
jacob jake hassan spoke at hustle khan
this was like pre d to c even being a
word okay so jacob cassan he launched
his company called movement or cassin
sorry launched this company called
movement they were shitty watches from
china uh they ordered a bunch and they
start selling them on movement.com or
whatever then they kind of make them a
little bit better but they're still like
not the most high quality watches and
his company he sold that thing for 200
million dollars and again if you would
have showed me this watch i'd be like
you are crazy no one's gonna buy this
this is just ridiculous and i've talked
to him and he's like well why not like
people buy watches why won't they buy
mine i think that confidence is awesome
and i love it i don't know if i have it
but i love it
yeah it takes it definitely takes guts
and i think you know one thing i've
learned is that these spaces uh so
there's like there's there's the niche
spaces which we love
and then there's also the everybody
everyday problems and that's what like
keeping beverages hot and cold is and i
think you want to go on one end of the
spectrum or the other you need to go
hyper niche where it's like yeah i'm you
know for a specific type of toe fungus
this is the uh this is the best cream
and i'm just going to target that and on
the other side you go everybody everyday
problems and i'm just going to try to
sell this thing because my ads will
apply to everybody and so there's
basically like
you know like i've been looking at
different water brands so what's the one
in austin so there's like lacroix or
whatever it's like kind of like a larger
chico baby like it
well chico has been around for a while
what's the one that's like the startup
that lance armstrong invested in that's
yeah guys in austin uh let me look it up
i know you're talking about water or
something like water waterloo is that it
yeah that's it
i think it's waterloo okay so there's
waterloo they got huge they're like oh
yeah we're at 50 million in sales
there's a brand called ugly water
founder sent me a case of that thank you
for that uh ugly water again
cool sparkling water crushing it doing
millions of millions of dollars in sales
and i'm like dude how many more of these
can there be liquid death we had liquid
death on probably 100 million in sales
yeah exactly so you know
you know just bottled water again like
you know canned water sparkling water uh
like my trainer was talking to me
yesterday and he's like bro let's start
a coconut water brand i was like yeah we
should because you know what like uh
coconut water is a massive market and
like you could just go in and do more
he's from hawaii so he's like bro like i
grew up on this stuff we can we can
brand it right we can get it out there
and i was like okay cool let me find an
operator so if somebody wants to start a
coconut water brand with me just email
me sean shawnproof.com because i want to
start one and by start what i mean i
want you to do most of the work and i'll
do uh
virtually nothing okay um so so let's
let's do that split can you can you talk
about this guy uh khan the nfl owner
yes oh by the way can i do two quick
updates yeah one um
uh there's a guy you know you talked
about like just buying a giant ranch by
giant farmland or whatever there's a guy
who hit me up he's very credible who's
like i'll do this for you guys like i
will go find it i'll i'll find the right
thing i'll acquire i'll get the permits
i'll build it out um and like you know
let's just partner on it and so uh i
love this podcast because it basically
matches
dude you get all like
why is it the ugly water guy
why is an ugly water guy setting me
water why is it ranch guy sitting
that's what i was into
yeah you're into it i think my email is
easier to find i don't know and people
people just guess my email easier like i
often dude my email's the same as yours
sam sampard.com it's literally the exact
same let me tell you this let me tell
you this
so a youtuber reached out so shout out
to rebecca who's a a youtuber who
reached out she's got 10 million youtube
subscribers amazing she's a big star
channel's awesome and um she's a fan of
the pod and she had emailed reached out
and said hey i listen to the pod or her
i think her husband reached out or her
brother or business manager somebody
reached out and said hey it's her
birthday tomorrow she'd love to like
meet you guys as like a birthday present
no she didn't say you guys
okay she said whatever she said but she
put both of our emails they had both of
our emails on there but for you what
they have like holler at thehustle.com
which i don't know if that's a real
email or not
i went back and looked and it's holler
maybe it's even spelled wrong i don't
know is holler your email address no
that's not my email address maybe that's
why i didn't get it
[__] i don't know i don't even know what
that is
i
i can tell by the the word holler at the
hustle i guarantee you made that up one
day yeah years ago that was supposed to
be our help email
exactly i guarantee you like just holler
at me like we'll fix it just holler at
me
exactly all right anyways uh was gonna
tell you the other one the other update
is um this guy sent me a screenshot he's
like ten thousand dollars he goes thank
you for that idea i don't remember we
had done an idea either here on twitter
about
uh moving bins this is a very simple
idea which is like when you move you
need these like packing bins just like
these plastic heavy duty bins so you
don't have to do boxes so you pack all
your stuff you move to your other place
you unpack you unpack it you just return
the bin so you just rent these bins for
the day while you move and i had like
done done the numbers i was like this
thing is kind of great it's like okay
maybe you can't buy a property and rent
it out but you can buy 50 of these bins
and rent them out and you can make good
money and so he emailed he's like hey
it's been a long sweat like i'm not
saying it was easy but
you know i bought ten thousand dollars
made from these bins and uh you know
thanks for the idea i just really
appreciate that that's you know uh it's
kind of been a great side income for me
in my city and i'm like oh this is cool
like that's that's the best feeling of
this whole podcast is basically if we
throw the ideas out there and then
people actually run with them and make
something happen out of it
so let me tell you something about that
first of all that's amazing so have you
ever been to the grocery store and seen
one of those carpet cleaners
carpet cleaners like uh what do you mean
like a vacuum or something else yeah so
it looks like a vacuum but it's it's
meant for um
it looks like a vacuum
no it's like you push it you've never
seen one of these so like people oh like
this is a heavy-duty carpet cleaning
like like more like a deep clean yes and
people rent those for like 200 a day you
know what i'm talking about
uh yeah i know like it's kind of like
the equivalent of power washing or
something like that but for your carpet
yes okay so i was thinking i was like
looking at this and they a lot of them
have a meter on there and they and
that's like the hours
the hours that uh it can go for i've
been logged have been logged so like
they it's like a dirt bike or like a
boat where it's like instead of saying
how many miles does it have on it's how
many hours and so a lot of these things
a lot of these carpet cleaners they can
last for something like um five years so
let's i i i don't know if this is make
up a number yeah long time yeah so i
don't know if this is exactly how it
would work but let's say three and sixty
five or fif there's 52 weeks in a year
52 times
uh 40 let's see i'm just doing it really
quick 260. so you're in public math are
you no i'm doing it on my computer okay
so we don't do public math so a lot of
these things will last like 10 to 15 000
hours and they rent out for like 200 a
day which comes out to be like you know
20 an hour i think buying and renting
carpet cleaners is one of the greatest
like
banks for your money when i went i went
to the grocery store and i just looked i
was like how much does this cost and i
looked at how much they cost to buy they
cost like 800 to buy
so this thing at the grocery store that
i keep seeing all i would see it all the
time and then i i once i saw those i
would say to the people like how often
do those rent for uh do people rent them
a lot and they're like yeah all the time
they're always being rented out it's
like one of the greatest things i've
ever seen when i was like doing the math
i'm like this is brilliant the carpet
goes back to our teenage side hustle
like if you're a teenager or you have a
teenager just get one of these and then
teach your teenager how to make like
kind of like one page sales letters and
yelp ads and basically just drop the
sales letters in uh you know under
everyone's door uh every month so you're
gonna print out a hundred of these put
them in your neighborhood and just say
hey hey y'all i live over here at 37
terrace woodway
and uh i bought this cleaner it's
amazing here's the before and after of
my carpet but
you know i'm not going to use this you
know i only needed to use it once and it
made such a big difference but i still
got the thing if you want it i'll rent
it out to you for 40 bucks just text me
here i'll bring it to your house if you
want your carpet clean and if you want
me to do it for you i'll do it for 150
and uh and you know just do that and
like that's such a good teenage side
hustle uh because you know you'll learn
sales you'll learn marketing you'll
learn a little bit of like unit
economics it's just a little way to get
kind of make your first dollar i think
making your first dollar is massively
underrated like i didn't make my first
dollar my first hustle dollar where like
not like a job where i was you know
sitting at a cash register all day but
like me creating a product and selling
it to somebody i didn't do that till i
was like 19.
i i'm sure you did it earlier because i
think you were flipping stuff on ebay or
something you i think you were more of a
hustler early on than me well yeah but
ebay ebay doesn't feel like the first
dollar though
uh maybe it does it's kind of like you
had the scheme it's not a job basically
like you're kind of like first dollar
out of business yeah and
in high school
but by the way 19 is very young dude
uh actually maybe maybe later i thought
you were going to say like 30.
it was 21 or 22 right right after i
graduated and um so it's probably 22
actually and so like you know i wish
that that 22 was 12. i think that it's
like learning languages or you know like
working out like the earlier you learn
these core skills the better and so uh
you know if you if you're sitting there
and you even if you're 29 right now 39
whatever it is and you're at a job
you've just never done this i really
encourage you to go make your first
dollar as a side hustle as a business
make a product or find a product and
sell it and um
you know it'll it's surprising how it'll
kind of like change the way you look at
things
yeah i agree that's what i told sarah
when she was doing her course i'm like
if you just get make one dollar and it's
gonna change your life um can you tell
me about this con guy i love this guy
okay yeah all right this is the billy of
the week and by the way uh by the way we
should have been pop on ben ben come on
here real quick we got a new producer
and one of the things i'm gonna ask him
to do is for our little segments make
sure we do our segments like billy of
the week people love that segment we
should do it and two
uh we gotta have like a little sound a
little jingle a little something
whenever we go to this segment i think
and ben ben's the host of the how to
take for the world podcast if you're not
subscribed to that do it he did this
those edison episodes that we released
about thomas edison he's almost done our
show now he has almost a hundred
thousand listens a month
all right ben okay big dog i'm surprised
you're even still here with that big
number
uh not not for long sean if you keep
pumping me up like this then you're not
gonna your head's not even gonna fit
into this i agree with that zoom window
um we'll we'll try out a sound we'll
play something on this episode a little
like billy of the week jingle and see
how people feel about it all right
sounds good and you got to replace abreu
at the end when we used to ask about you
how we did and he gave us the straight
talk
million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
[Music]
anyways back to the billy of the week so
this guy his name is shahid khan
he's from pakistan and he his story is
kind of insane so here's the guy who
moved to america at age 16.
first job is a dishwasher for i think a
dollar sixty an hour
and um you know so he starts making a
dollar sixty an hour and today he's
worth nine billion dollars personally
and uh how the heck did he do that so do
you know this guy's story um a little
bit i know him because he's incredibly
recognizable he's like he's kind of
beautiful like if he he he looks he
looks like a badass a little bit he
looks like a badass
well he looks like someone who's i built
respect and fear because they seem
formidable and also they look like they
like to party
yeah he's got a [__] sick mustache
basically that's his like iconic thing
he's got one of the mustaches that's
like almost a twirled at the end it's
amazing so he looks really special is
the way i would describe him in a good
way um okay so what is the story so he
he starts off dishwasher he's like
sleeping at the ymca
and like you know now that he's super
rich he like donates millions of dollars
to the ymca because he's like dude i
used to sleep in here i used to hide in
the ymca and sleep because it was so
cold outside and i didn't i couldn't
afford like you know where i was
supposed to live and so he um
so he got rich by he made his millions
by or his billions really
by building custom bumpers for cars so
car bumpers truck bumpers car bumpers
that sort of thing so here's like how it
all works so he he graduates as an
engineering student and he gets a job at
this company that does manufacturing for
uh for bumper for car bumpers and he
kind of like works his way up first few
years i think he's there for maybe five
seven years something like that he's
eventually like kind of like leading the
engineering operations and he's sort of
like man this is so inefficient the way
we do this we get all these different
parts and we try to like jam them
together to make this car bumper it's
really heavy it's really clunky it's
kind of ugly
and um and i think the company was
called flexing gate or later it was
called flexing gate but uh he's working
at this company and he along the way
he's sort of like he's trying to
convince the company like hey we should
change the design but they're not really
listening to him so he's like all right
screw it i'm gonna spin out my own
company and i'm gonna design my own
bumpers and so he quits he takes uh yeah
i think he has 16 000 in personal
savings he takes like a 50 000
sba loan
and he goes and he creates his own uh
bumper company right and so he
he starts uh trying to go get clients
trying to go get customers and he's
getting you know some small customers
and along the way as he's making
progress
he gets sued by his previous employer
they're like hey you stole trade secrets
and uh you're competing your competition
now so like screw you we're gonna we're
gonna sue you and he's like [__] like um
they're way bigger than me i can't
afford you know i can't afford a lawyer
basically so i'm like how am i gonna
fight this in court and i know their
strategy their strategy is gonna be like
they just um they just bleed me out
right like they're bigger than me this
is gonna cost both of us money but
they're they have deeper pockets so he
comes up with a strategy where he hires
the cheapest lawyer he could find
just to sort of like stall the case
and then like so it's costing him almost
nothing to continue it's costing them a
lot of money they're losing a lot of
money on this lawsuit and then he starts
studying every night like after the
business operations are done he goes to
the library and he starts studying law
so that he can defend himself in court
because he hires this kind of like saul
goodman you know type of character and
just you know wants to defend himself so
he starts educating himself
and um
so he ends up winning the case and along
the way that company flexing gate was
losing like 50 000 a month and so they
were their business wasn't very healthy
so by the end he wins the case and he
just ends up it takes the money and he
has the money from his business and he
buys out flexing gates so he buys out
the company that was suing him it's like
a kind of like a [__] you plus a
consolidation of like how much should he
pay for it do you know
i don't know the exact number that he
ended up uh buying him for but you know
sort of like baller move uh going back
there and he had designed this bumper
that was like a slick kind of like
one continuous piece so it wasn't a
bunch of pieces put together and it was
way more lightweight and so all of a
sudden the car companies were like oh
this is great we want to have a lighter
weight thing it's better for fuel
efficiency it's easier for manufacturing
it's cheaper fantastic so they start
going to him and so he starts getting
like these contracts and there's like
all these little sub stories in here
that like i don't want to dive too far
into but like he wants to get the like
suzuki contract and so he like hires a
bunch of people who know to speak
japanese he starts learning all about
the culture he like goes there because
he's like
i have to go further than anyone else is
gonna go to win this deal because i'm a
no-name brand but i have a great product
and if i can make these guys trust me
and believe in me this will work so he
lands suzuki shortly after that he gets
the big toyota contract now like as of
today i think he's basically making like
every automaker's bumpers like i think
you know there's like 20 million plus
cars that are have his bumper something
ridic some ridiculous number like 30 of
all cars use his bumpers and so you know
the company um does billions and
billions of dollars his personal net
worth has ballooned to where he uh
he owns nine billion dollars or he's
worth nine billion dollars i believe as
his personal net worth and then he's
done a bunch of other things so he
bought the jacksonville jaguar so he
wanted to own an nfl team
and he tries to buy the denver broncos
but at the last minute the guy who was
the minority owner had to write a first
refusal and like exercised it and bought
the broncos out from under him stand
cronky and so he's like ah [__] but he
became friends with the guys who are the
the people who in the jaguars he buys
the jaguars and he starts doing some
pretty interesting things so the jaguars
are kind of like
one of the bottom of the barrel team
yeah
and they're still not great right
they're not great they've never they've
had like very small windows of time
where the team was good but it's never
like a high profile franchise really
it's like one of the small markets
and so he's like okay how do i play the
game to like how do i use this to my
advantage so he's like all right ticket
sales are low and he starts to dig into
why it's like oh it's just so expensive
to come to a game the average fan is
priced out
so he does something like pretty radical
like he um
he uh
he made it where any fan can bring their
own food to the games which is like the
opposite of what every other stadium
tries to do where they're like uh you
know low ticket but then we'll charge
you like 30 for a hot dog yeah he was
like bring your own food and what ends
up happening is ticket sales go up and i
think food revenue went up when they got
to the stadium like you know some
counter-intuitive result like that
and um you know he started doing a bunch
of other things like he
uh he put a fantasy football tracker in
the stadium on the scoreboard he's like
oh fans
you know they're not just here to watch
the game they're here for entertainment
and part of their entertainment is their
fantasy team so he like would show your
points while you're while you're there
and people got a kick out of that and he
like pimped out the locker room for the
players he's like i want to have like
the best locker room very similar things
to what mark cuban did with the with the
dallas mavs by the way so similar sort
of playbook he now owns awe which is
like a head-to-head competitor with wwe
like vince mcmahon's thing so it's like
a wrestling wrestling thing he's got
this crazy yacht called kismet which is
like a i don't know it's like a
i don't know how much this yacht cost
but to rent it cost 1.2 million per week
and that excludes food fuel and dockage
costs and so like you know beyonce and
jay-z rented this thing out for their
italy vacation uh i think it's like a
200 million dollar yacht that he rents
out for a million dollars a week
dude that's nuts what do you uh what's
your biggest takeaway from him
um i just love this sort of like i mean
this rags to a story is kind of like
amazing and i think it's
uh it's inspiring and so i think there's
a lot of people who who
could do this you're in a company you
see things done inefficiently and if you
had the guts you would basically be able
to spin out
and like you know your own competitor
inside and out because you were there as
a leader and so you know where their
weaknesses are you know what the
customer needs are and you know if you
start to chip away like you can make a
lot more than you would ever make
climbing the corporate ladder there and
then i loved some of the like
atypical bets that he was making or
moves that he's making like going into
wrestling i think is super interesting
most people don't think about that or
there's no way that will work by the way
there's no way well i think it's already
made made quite quite a bit because he
bought he bought this
i think he bought the thing for dirt
cheap
and there's just like there's always a
perpetual number two to wwe so he
doesn't need to become wwe right like
yes there is a long shot
bull case where you know he ends up
overtaking it but there's always been a
number two like wcw back in the day or
like you know the local uh the local
shows and whatnot and so i think that
there's a lot of money in even being
like a really strong credible number two
and i think wwe ends up buying all their
competition and so he might end up
flipping it to them someday um but it
takes like some deep pockets so it might
fail like you know that's okay
but i like these types of bits it's
inspiring to me like a guy like this
yeah i think it's really cool i'm
reading there's an awesome article about
him in the new york times it's an old
one it's about from 2011 and basically
it says jaguar's buyer had his eyes on
had his eyes on owner ownership
franchise and the dream has come true
and he talks about like how it's been
his dream to do that and the whole like
immigrant uh you know like this was like
the the to me this is an american things
to own a team and i think that's really
great so anyway i think it's cool he
gets a lot of racism stuff too by the
way i was reading about that like in
jacksonville there's a bunch of ticket
holders who canceled it because
an american didn't own the team now and
he's like dude like we are americans but
uh you know so i think he's
even even even still you know still
fighting certain battles yeah i do of
course um and i dig this this is a good
one i feel like every ability of the
wheat that we've ever done is like
basically an immigrant there's
definitely a recurring theme here
we got to do an american billy born and
bred american billy of the week no i
like the immigrant stories i prefer
those um let me tell you about a cool
app that i found um well it's a web app
so a website it's called [__] you pay me
and so the ur the url is f
y p m dot vip it's kind of confusing but
i just sent it to you
and it's in the dock actually as well
and i just sent it on riverside and so
[__] you pay me so basically what it is
it's the it's kind of glass door slash
yelp for influencers and so if you are
an influencer you can log on and you can
see which brands are easy to work with
and how much they pay and people want to
work with them again and i think this is
interesting
for a couple reasons
the biggest one is well like this is
cool but the second reason why i like
this is because these types of
businesses i actually think are
incredibly easy to set up and if you
could start getting reviews and if you
could start getting people to use it
very valuable so basically this website
it i don't know what it's built with but
i bet you that there's some just like
it's probably a wordpress uh like a
login or something like that like very
very very simple stuff you could you
could build this in like two or three
days and there's another good example of
this and that that's called um
uh
vcguide.com so we're talking about
influencers and venture capitalists
because that's in our world but have you
ever been a vc guide dot co
yeah i've been to it yeah
okay so it's it's the most basic looking
website you've ever seen and it's just a
list of names and people
vote on and or leave reviews on
different venture capitalists but anyway
i think that this is a really really
cool business and i love this idea
there's another one that i was looking
at called niche niche.com which is not
small but they like it's the same type
of thing but just they do it for schools
and so i think that there's a lot of
really cool businesses that could be
built with this model another one that i
think could exist and similar to
influencers is
like basically all the publishers out
there like bustle
um who else i don't i mean whatever just
all they pay freelancers buy the article
or buy the word and i think that you
could if you wanted to you could do a
price per article for publishers you
could do how much anyone pays for
anything basically in terms of freelance
work and so anyway i think this is a
cool business it's called [__] you pay
me i think it's awesome
yeah i think this is cool as like a i
think it was started by a couple
influencers right yeah but i don't i
don't remember their name
yeah so i think it's a good um
like scratching their own edge right
like at some point they get tired of
working with clients that don't pay up
on time or or try to remake on the deal
and they say look if we band together we
can do this and they already have a
network of other friends who do this
they have trust they know the problem so
i think that's a great
niche niche business to start and if
you're in a world like in an industry
the i think these are actually easier to
build like for example if you are in the
automotive world automotive
manufacturing and you have 50 friends
who
work in that business you could pretty
like easily kind of get this going and
it becomes addicting i remember i'm not
on vc guy thank god i'm not a vc but i
do invest but like let's see are you on
it sean like you start checking your
name all the time
yeah exactly you want to know what are
people saying about me yeah you check it
all the time and so anyway i think like
they're i think these are really
interesting and uh this is kind of a
cool one
i have a super quick idea i'll just do
that's related to this i saw this
company i should give them a shout out i
think it's called pump um and what
they're doing is actually pretty cool
it's
um you know like investor so you wrote
great investor updates i used to be on
your i wasn't an investor in the hustle
but you used to send me the updates uh i
don't know why just it was cool like i
could see it um and you wrote really
great investor updates like it was clear
it was like just the right mix of like
the info you need not too much and not
too little and you had like a clear ask
if you needed something i see a lot i
see a lot of companies using that same
template i don't know if i stole that
if i took that from someone or like you
like kevin lee from uh the ramen company
his updates look exactly the same i
don't know what it is but that that
style i feel like is everywhere now
yeah i don't know where you got it from
but it's great i wish more of the
founders i invested in would do it
because mine don't do that that's all up
there they're either like ultra detailed
like we hired this engineer and this
person and they used to work here it's
like all right i really just okay i'm
glad you did that but like what does
that matter to me like it's too in the
weeds for where i'm at to help your
business and then they'll leave out like
here's how many customers we have and
here's how much money is in the bank
here's what we need here's what our
goals are like they'll leave that out
but they'll go into like ultra detail
about other stuff so um anyways
i think in general investor updates take
a lot of time they're really healthy
practice but they're sort of like
writing books right now it's like you do
this thing once a month or every couple
months
and you write it take some time to read
take some time to
to write
and i saw this company pumped i was
basically just saying take your cap
table and it lets you do like twitter
sized updates about your company so you
can just like post a photo of something
cool that's going on or a chart what's
the url
uh i don't know the url i think the
brand i think the app or the company's
called pump i think it's pretty it might
even be public i might have to bleep it
out
um
but i was looking at it as a potential
investment
uh because i really like this idea i
think that uh
updates that are more frequent will
actually be more transparent will
actually be more useful it will be more
easy to read but easier to write it'll
get more interaction between the
investors and the founder because i can
just hit the like button or i can just
write a quick reply like looks awesome
or have you talked to this person
they're doing something else check out
this
and um i think this is actually a way
better way to do investor updates it's
basically like a private twitter feed
for just you and your investors and um
that expectation of a bite-sized bit of
content is great
and it's on the uh
play
play store i don't even know what what
the [__] is the play store is that like
uh that's google
you know
dude i don't [__] use it no i don't
know anything about that uh i'm looking
at it now
you're the craziest thing i've ever
heard
dude i've never been on the play store
in my life i didn't even know what that
was see this like blue collar everyday
sam
and it's like what is android
[Laughter]
i i i i'm sorry i don't know one person
that uses android do you
of course
like
[Music]
the pixel's got an amazing camera it's
amazing dude i don't know one person
like closely
i just thought everyone uses an iphone
except if you have android and you're in
my group chat
you're out of my group chat bro like
you're killing the group chat with your
inability to like send pictures and and
all that it's horrible but i'm looking
at pump it's also in the app store i
actually think this is cool there was
this other company that people were
were saying was gonna be really cool i
forget the name of it you might remember
it though and it was like how to
collaborate with your investors better
what was that called start with a c
cabal i think that's the one i saw cabal
it seemed okay this seems way way
interesting i think this is better that
cabal has a bunch of like cool people
using it and invested in it so it might
have like the the important people doing
that but uh how did you find that i like
this product better uh how did you find
scout found this dude i have a lot of
help zach found this one uh for uh faraz
found the billy of the week and sent it
to me because he'd been on the guy's
yacht and sent me a picture of it and
was like you got to feature this guy uh
it's
a lot of my ideas don't come for me
wow no that's amazing um i would i would
invest in that company yeah i think
that's really cool
um if you're the founder hit us up we
want it we want to invest in that all
right you want to do one more thing or
you want to save it
we should save it this episode is going
to be a little crazy we'll see if it's
interesting
oh um you want to talk about my
influencer update
yeah
you're like let's save it but i want to
talk about this well because that's
actually not important so we could hide
it at the end this was actually what i
was going to start with because i found
this hilarious uh and awesome and i
wanted to know what you're actually
doing because like you said it as a joke
so sam texts the other day he goes
i think i think you were joking but
you're like half serious no i was not
maybe
you were not serious or not joking i
think i was serious yes you're more
serious than joking
so sam texts i'm thinking about stopping
trying to be a business influencer and
just go to be a fitness influencer i
don't know if my face is good enough
though
and so then i'm like okay just some kind
of random funny text didn't think much
of it and then you sent me this link to
this reddit post where you're like my
fitness journey you're like here i'm at
you know 12 body fat and here's my
photos and here's what i'm doing i'm
like oh [__] he's actually trying to do
it so what is this what are you doing so
did you see my instagram thing
the video yeah i saw your video yeah
so here's why i think it's cool
um i love exercise i love to work out
and i'm a little
bored of just business content and i
look up so you want to know what i we're
going to talk about this next episode
but here's what i do late at night late
at night i go to instagram and i love
watching videos of ripped guys stretch
do you ever watch
like
no no i never do that i don't i don't
i've never done something like that dude
there's these guys this is like getting
really popular right now there's these
dudes who they do calisthenics and
they're like sitting on like these bars
and they like move their legs above
their head or they uh they like do the
splits or and they're not like jacked
like dudes but they're like skinnyish
very flexible and i'm like this is the
way to live life 100 percent to be
skinny and flexible and there's just i
just in my head i'm like they're just
stretching all day and filming it that
seems awesome i can do that and so
that's kind of like how i want to live
my life right now is i like watch these
guys do like the you know what your
thoracic thoracic spine is
yes
it's upper back so because like we sit
hunched over like everyone's got like a
hunchback kind of and so yeah the
thoracic it's like i think it's really
good to stretch and so i just watch
videos of guys stretch her thoracic
spine i love nick bear nick bear was
this huge beast of a guy who came on our
podcast and he has this like pretty cool
business and he just like runs marathon
and lifts weights all day and i see this
and i'm like that sounds awesome i
totally want to do that also
additionally i'm a little i got a little
once like we sold the company i got a
little depressed because i was like i
live such a soft [__] life like i don't
have any real threats in my life i never
have to fight i never have to get like i
never got to go hunt for my food i never
am like afraid of getting eaten by a
lion like i need some action and
adventure yeah i'm too comfortable
and so i was like this fitness thing
seems cool like let's just learn how to
box or let's just do something like
interesting and just document it and i
and i've loved it and so i am not joking
i think i might do this
but when you say might do this what does
that actually mean you're going to try
to literally become a fitness influencer
meaning like you want to be sam uh you
know sami hamstrings who's got like
amazing
amazing hamstring stretches or like what
do you actually want what is the goal i
think i could build a large following i
don't i i've besides like checking like
other people's pictures i don't post on
instagram at all and for some reason i
have like 5 000 followers so i think
that's a good base i think i could build
up this like reputation as this like
fitness slash businessy type of guy
okay fitness business but you're talking
specifically about stretching or no any
any fitness is fine uh i'm gonna focus
on boxing and weightlifting right now
because that's what i love but i think
stretching is like the way to go yes
like there's so many people who google
uh different stretching stuff dude i'm
telling you this this whole mobility
movement it's huge
and how committed are you to this
i mean i work out constantly like so
actually to the influencer part i know
you're committed to
doing the fitness stuff i haven't
decided how uh
committed i am because
well what was the reaction to your
reddit and instagram thing because that
probably just gave you a bunch of jet
fuel of motivation to keep going well
the pr it was good i mean the reddit the
thing that read it was interesting i
just posted on a subreddit called guess
my body fat and like people but then
i wasn't caring about that when i told
you what i was caring about is that
someone said your body fat is probably
this i don't know about sean perry's and
i was like oh my god that's crazy
someone like recognizes us and so but
the instagram thing that i posted it got
popular but the thing is is that i
actually think that like getting famous
on social media is really cool and also
it will make you very unhappy and so
that's my biggest thing the biggest
thing i'm nervous about is like do i
actually want to spend time on this and
go down this like
hedonistic uh like uh you know
dedicating my life to something that
maybe isn't actually that cool or
important but it does seem kind of neat
so anyway that's my rant i'm becoming a
fitness influencer i think i could do it
i think i'd like have girl next door
like a girl next to her body
you know what i mean like not likely
dude that's so true it's like not
intimidating you're not on a you're not
unachievable but you're also impressive
so it's like yeah
i'm into it
but i feel like with enough work i too
could be there yeah i got like he's just
a regular guy
i got girl next door uh abs like you
know like you can do it too
and you have been doing it by the way
you look great
well i'm trying but i'm i'm far behind
where you're at yeah but i had a head
start
it would have been fun if uh like when i
saw you post that thing i was like oh
damn okay so i've been doing this for
one year now uh it's time to do this for
a while okay let me see
you know it sort of put into perspective
like
actually the girl the guy next door
thing you said it's so true because
that's actually the feeling i had which
was i was like
you know when i look at random people on
instagram that are really ripped it
doesn't do anything for me because i'm
like well i'm not trying to do that i'm
not trying to be a gorilla like i'm not
trying to like have 19 you know 19 abs
but like
four four nice abs that seems like both
achievable and desirable to me so i
actually think you're on to something
with this guy next door vibe that's what
i'm saying it's like everything every
our podcast people say oh you guys make
everything seem so easy and achievable
and i'm like and what do we say we're
like it kind of is you got to put in the
work but like it's not that hard in an
election yeah because we're not that
smart nor are we that successful nor are
we that nor do we do that much research
so there's there's a
a relatability to us
we're not smarter than you we're not
that much more successful than you and
we definitely don't do a ton of research
on each individual topic so we're not
that much more of an expert than you on
anything
this is my thing i might just translate
that to like getting shredded and being
fit and like living a long healthy life
that's why it's interesting to me also
the same way that whenever you post
stuff uh like people send you free [__]
like that drink company or like you know
you have you have a lot of like people
who email you with amazing opportunities
it would be cool to get that for workout
related stuff so that's one of the
reasons why i want to do it did i show
you this have i shown you this it's an
axe
i'm holding up an axe for those who are
just listening not on the youtube
channel and it's called
chop fit so this guy sent me this dude
[__] i don't get [__] i don't get
anything
bro there's a method to the madness uh i
think we asked for it or we told him
like i saw this thing and we messaged
him be like hey this is awesome he's
like oh i'd love to send you one
it's really what i do i basically just
have a bunch of dms that are for
products i think are cool and i just say
yo
shopfit looks dope
congrats you know like something like
that and they're like oh thank you
that's amazing and i'm like yeah i'd
love to try it or yeah i'm excited to
try it
i just let them fill it in with like
yeah here you go anyway so he sent me
this i'm looking at the website this is
a weighted axe so it's basically peloton
the reason i'm showing you this dude
isn't this just
a jammer
it's yeah but it's like more there's two
of these so you get two of these so you
have two of these to work out with one
in each hand and it's sort of like a
peloton but like okay like i like the
idea of peloton i like the idea of
guided classes but i'm not into biking
like i don't love biking i don't love
running on a treadmill so like i have
the aqua bag boxing bag in my garage
because i love hitting the aqua bag it's
like super fun to me i love aqua bags
too so that's really cool and then this
is the new toy i'm starting to play with
which is like
i like swinging this thing around
there's something that feels fun about
this it feels like i'm about to like
kill somebody and uh you can get a
pretty sick core workout with this thing
and like kind of it also works the uh
forearms really well too because you're
holding an axe which is like you ever
seen like a lumberjack those guys arms
or their forearms are insane do me a
favor
tonight or tomorrow whenever you're
gonna go work out again just do it
shirtless do it outside in the sun and
take a video of you doing this and post
it on twitter and i promise you it'll
get at least 25 000 views people are
gonna like comment to you and it's gonna
a comment about you and it's gonna feel
awesome you're gonna become a fitness
center too i work out with no shirt
every day in the sun every day it feels
amazing to do is record the whole thing
i take snippets because i'm
i'm you're going from fit to really fit
i'm going from fat to fit and so there's
a big difference you got to strategy you
got to be strategic right like you don't
want to just post a before it's got to
be like slightly impressive yeah yeah
yeah you got like a montage that goes
from shitty to like oh that's really
good no in your case it's like okay so
i'm storing up my ammo for the epic
montage
you're like right now you're like
there's like before and way before
yeah exactly
i'm i'm i'm a good before photo now
but i had a way before that i've been
had been working towards i'm not after
yet so i'm i'm waiting for the afternoon
that's a bad move maybe i should be
posting everything but i think
it has a bigger impact
if i do the before and after because it
should be impressive when you do it
okay well this is the episode where
we've just decided we're both going to
become fitness influencers i think you
should post a picture of that i think i
don't want to be a fitness influencer
but i do want uh to like
do it myself i've never done this i've
never been somebody who's like ripped
um you start posting the reason why one
of the reasons another reason why i'm
doing it is i said out there i'm gonna
so right now i weigh 203 pounds i and
i'm probably
i'm 12 maybe 14 body fat which is okay
that's pretty good um i said i put it on
there i want to weigh 185 in three
months and a lot of people saw that and
now if they see me out there eating like
an idiot they're gonna like confront me
and i think that that accountability is
actually really good no like like it
like my in-laws
you know saw me and they're like oh we
know we're not gonna eat we're not gonna
we can't go to this place for dinner
anymore uh right you know what i mean
like that type of thing
yeah that's funny all right uh ben how
did we do um
this one was weird
was weird but i think people are really
gonna like it i think people like weird
uh i actually think the
uh
body influencer stuff was really good
eight point five out of ten overall okay
all right i'll take that for a while
what was the what was the weakest part
um
the weakest part has been forgettable
was
um
i would say probably the middle talking
about like water bottles and stuff like
that that was
interesting but just the weakest the
strongest was like the energy audit uh
stuff time tracking sleep talk like when
you guys work i think that was super
strong started super strong ended super
strong when talking about your like
fitness journey all right good well
let's see how the sam hose water thing
was by far my favorite part of the whole
episode
is that a real thing people used to call
you hose water or that was no but
like i love hose water you don't drink
out of hoses bro dude are you are you
considered funny because i find you
really really funny but you're funny in
a surprising way and i feel like you
think you're funny
but almost that other people don't give
you credit for being really funny i
think that i'm not that funny and i
think most people don't think i'm funny
really oh i don't think you know you're
funny
i think people most people do not find
my humor to be i got like a norm
mcdonald humor you're either into it or
you're not
[Laughter]
uh just so everyone has like the
background that that joke that shawn
told of sam saying i'm gonna own a lake
someday he posted it in slack and then
like badgered us like five times
afterwards like did you guys see that
joke was it a good job anybody read that
it was pretty good
and then and then we were like yeah it
was good and then
ben comes in he's like
sean it was really funny when you said
this thing and sam was like what the
hell dude my leg joke was way better
than that
oh my god
this makes our life sound cooler than it
really is
future owner of the lakers future owner
of a lake all right
[Music]